geschäfts minister robert habeck wird
jetzt stufe 2 den notfall des
notfallplans verkünden es geht um unsere
energie das heißt um ihren geldbeutel ja
der hintergrund ist klar dass putin den
gashahn für deutschland immer weiter
zugedreht hat und weiter zudreht und
jetzt die worte von robert habeck zu
dieser pressekonferenz eingeladen um sie
darüber zu informieren dass wir nach
abstimmung in der bundesregierung
gestern und nach informationen der
europäischen partner heute jetzt in
diesem moment die alarmstufe gas
ausrufen wir haben in deutschland eine
störung der gasversorgung so ist
definiert daher ist es erforderlich
diese alarmstufe auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland das sage ich obwohl oder
gerade weil die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland aktuell gewährleistet ist
der markt ist also in der lage die
mengen die benötigt werden um die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland zu
gewährleisten und auch die speicher
moderat anzufüllen auf dem markt zu
besorgen
dennoch und das zwingt uns zu diesem
schritt heute darf die aktuelle lage uns
nicht in eine falsche sicherheit in
einer falschen sicherheit werden wir
haben nachdem in der letzten woche
russland gazprom unter einem
vorgeschobenen technischen argument die
gaslieferung auf der nord stream
pipeline um 60 prozent reduziert hat
verschiedene szenarien durchgerechnet
diese szenarien
zeige ich ihnen einmal
das ist nämlich ich finde sehr
anschaulich zu sehen wo man da gerade
steht die roten punkte sind die
gesetzlich vorgegebenen speicher soll
füllstände die blaue kurve also quasi
der optimale verlauf unter der annahme
von einer reduktion von nord stream 61
prozent also die minus 40 prozent ist
die kurve die wir erreichen sollen sie
ist allerdings nur möglich zu erreichen
unter der annahme dass wir nicht für das
europäische nachbarland aus speichern
das ist erstens ungesetzlich und
zweitens wäre es auch hat dort weil wir
ja darauf angewiesen sind dass die
europäischen länder uns beliefern also
niederlande norwegen benelux belgien
frankreich
alle diese länder
brauchen wir ja um überhaupt über
energie gas gas nach deutschland zu
bekommen insofern und das ist die
not das ist die erkenntnis die uns zu
diesem tag führt scheidet diese kurve
per logik und per gesetz aus bleiben die
verschiedenen anderen szenarien und sie
sehen hier ist die nulllinie hier sind
die speicher leer dass die meisten
szenarien uns sehr weit in die zone von
lehrern speichern führen deswegen greift
die definition des gesetzes ich brauche
mir sich einmal vorzulesen die
alarmstufe wird dann ausgerufen wenn
eine störung der gasversorgung oder eine
außergewöhnlich hohe nachfrage nach gas
vorliegt die zu einer erheblichen
verschlechterung der gas versorgungslage
führt den markt aber noch in der lage
ist diese störung oder nachfrage zu
bewältigen ohne das nicht mag basierte
maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen dieser
fall liegt vor wir haben uns die paar
tage zeit gelassen die szenarien
durchzurechnen das ist kein spiel wir
müssen einen so gravierenden schritt gut
kunden können und die begründung ist aus
meiner sicht schlagend
wir sind also jetzt gehalten die
gasverkäufe zu reduzieren jetzt schon im
sommer dann vor allem mit der
perspektive auf den winter und das ist
sicherlich
die trügerische wirklichkeit in der wir
uns im moment bewegen es ist sommer und
zwar ein sommer nach einer langen
pandemie zeiten ein will gerne draußen
die zeit genießen will auch vielleicht
mal ohne politische trübsal im kopf die
zeit genießen aber der winter wird ja
komm ein bisschen an sich jetzt die
vorsorge treffen um dann im winter
vorbereitet zu sein und alles daran
setzen dass wir mit vollen
speicherstände in den winter gehen
ich will ausdrücklich unterstreichen
dass diese situation ja immer eine
bedrohung war und so hat sich die
bundesregierung seit amtsantritt seit
dezember auf dieses szenario vorbereitet
wir haben früh angefangen alternative
infrastrukturen zu schaffen die lng
terminals mit hochgeschwindigkeit zu
bauen beziehungsweise die pipeline
anschluss zu bauen für die fsa user für
diversifizierung schiffe wir haben früh
angefangen mit steuergeld gasmengen zu
besorgen und für den winter zu kommen
beziehungsweise die
kapazitäten die nicht durch den markt
befüllt werden aufzufüllen das schließt
auch den speicher reden den gastraum
speicher reden mit ein wir haben die
verschiedenen gesetze geschrieben die es
uns jetzt ermöglichen auch
gesetzgeberisch tätig zu werden das gas
einspeicherung gesetz das energie
sicherungs gesetz all die gesetze zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren die sich jetzt
in der parlamentarischen beratung
befinden die also dann die energiemenge
hoffentlich zeitnah erhöhen
ich will und ich muss an dieser stelle
sagen dass sich natürlich auch recht
dass wir in den letzten jahren in
deutschland nicht gut genug waren es
sind die versäumnisse der letzten dekade
die uns jetzt in dieser bedrängnis
geführt haben und damit meine ich nicht
nur die politisch falsche abhängigkeit
von russland sondern auch die fehlende
bereitschaft alternativen zu schaffen
wie anders ständen wir da wenn wir die
letzten jahre in der energieeffizienz
und den ausbau der erneuerbaren wirklich
massiv voran gekommen wären statt
einfach nur im stillstand zu verharren
das rächt sich jetzt und muss mit großer
geschwindigkeit aufgeholt werden
dass das nicht von heute auf morgen geht
es einen klar aber von heute auf
übermorgen sollte erreichbar sein um
dieses übermorgen zu erreichen sind wir
gezwungen maßnahmen zu treffen die
wirklich weh tun wir haben sie schon am
wochenende angekündigt zu nennen sind
dass wir die
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve in den
betrieb bringen werden und somit gas vom
markt zu nehmen gas für die
elektrifizierung vom markt zu nehmen um
dieses gas dann ein speichern zu können
wir werden ein gas spar auktionsmodell
vorliegen das ist der industrie noch mal
erlaubt gegen geld ein um eine
umlagefinanzierung
gasverbraucher aus dem betrieb zu nehmen
und gestern hat nach beratungen im
haushaltsausschuss der gesetzgeber 15
milliarden euro für den markt
gebietsverantwortlichen also trading
europe das ist der die tochter
unternehmer der gasnetzbetreiber 15
milliarden euro freizugeben um gas
einzukaufen für die weitere speicherung
die alarmstufe gesetzlich geboten nach
den analysen die wir haben ist außerdem
die grundlage für weitere schritte und
die werden wir gehen sobald die gesetze
verabschiedet sind beziehungsweise
sobald die notwendigkeit es gebietet
zwei beispiele will ich nehme einmal im
parlamentarischen verfahren befindet
sich in der endabstimmung das
kraftwerksbereich haltungs gesetz
dieses gesetz ist dann die grundlage
dafür dass wir die kohlekraftwerke rein
nehmen können es wird wenn der bundestag
so dieses gesetz verabschiedet wie
geplant dann am 8.7 den bundesrat
passieren und dann werden die verordnung
vorliegen die teilweise an die ausrufung
der alarmstufe gebunden sind die
verordnung werden jetzt unter hochdruck
geschrieben und die kraftwerksbetreiber
die dann mit den verordnungen
ihre kohlekraftwerke in den markt
bringen sind angeschrieben worden dass
es so kommen wird die werden also jetzt
schon die kohle bereitstellen die
kraftwerke wieder flott machen für den
einsatz dann in zweieinhalb wochen
zweite was ich nennen will und was immer
mit der alarmstufe auch öffentlich
verknüpft wurde ist der paragraph 24
energie sicherungs gesetz endlich ist
der paragraph für die weitergabe von
preisen auch außerhalb der verträge
erlaubt er ist an die voraussetzung der
alarmstufe gebunden aber es gibt kein
automatismus und deswegen werden wir ihn
heute nicht ziehen noch nicht ausrufen
der grund ist dass wir den markt weiter
beobachten wollen die
ziehung des paragrafen 24n sieg ist
daran gebunden dass die
bundesnetzagentur eine weitere störung
und zwar eine strukturelle störung der
gras flüsse feststellt deswegen werden
wir haben wir die voraussetzung jetzt
hier mit geschaffen werden ihnen aber
auch heute noch nicht ausrufen
damit bin ich beim preis denn paragraf
24 ein sieg würde eine preis weitergabe
der gas betreiber außerhalb der verträge
bedeuten diese preise werden zu tragen
seien von der wirtschaft von den
verbrauchern und von den verbrauchern
und unabhängig davon ob man 24n sieht
oder nicht die preise kommen bei den
verbraucherinnen und bei den
verbrauchern an das was wir also hier im
moment erleben ist eine extreme
belastung für viele menschen für viele
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer diese
belastung ist ein externer schock es ist
ja nicht die
schlüssigkeit der deutschen
volkswirtschaft die uns zu dieser
situation geführt hat sondern der krieg
in russland und durch den krieg und
durch die politisch induzierten
verknappung von fossilen rohstoffen
die die der druck der im land aufgebaut
wurde diese preise müssen also getragen
wird dass sie fair getragen werden und
das ist entsprechend entlastung gibt für
die haushalte und für die unternehmen
die sich nicht leisten können das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen das boot
zu analysieren und dort abhilfe bzw
unterstützung zu schaffen bleibt als
letztes zu sagen dass wir obwohl es
sommer ist alle einen beitrag leisten
können die unternehmerin und die
unternehmer in dem sie schauen welche
einsparpotenziale noch da sind und ich
weiß dass sie das tun es gibt
berechnungen ist der gasverbrauch in der
deutschen industrie in den letzten
monaten ungefähr acht prozent
zurückgegangen ist
aber auch privathaushalte können ein
unterschied jetzt schon machen ich weiß
dass es manchmal banal klingt aber diese
banalität muss man immer mit 41
millionen haushalten multiplizieren und
bevor der winter kommt macht es eben
sinn die heizung noch einmal vernünftig
einzustellen oder einen hydraulischen
abgleich durchzuführen und die summen an
energie wie auch an geld die dort zu
sparen sind sind durchaus
erheblich bis zu 15 prozent
beispielsweise an
heizkostenersparnis kann man machen nur
durch den hydraulischen abgleich also
nur dadurch dass die heizung vernünftig
eingestellt sind und das wäre dann ja
entsprechend die energiemenge und das
nehmen wir jetzt mit 41 millionen
haushalten multipliziert und dann sieht
man dass die kleinen teilweise so
belächelten banalen schritte in der
summe dann doch einen großen unterschied
machen diesen unterschied müssen sie
aber machen wir befinden uns in einer
ökonomischen auseinandersetzung mit
russland gas und energie wird als waffe
gegen deutschland eingesetzt aus meiner
sicht mit dem ziel das was das land in
den letzten wochen und monaten
ausgezeichnet hat und europa
ausgezeichnet hat zu zerstören nämlich
eine große geschlossenheit eine große
solidarität mit der ukraine und eine
große bereitschaft für die verteidigung
von freiheit auf einen preis zu zahlen
über die preise watte soll genau dies
zerstört werden das wiederum darf nicht
passieren deswegen müssen alle
politischen maßnahmen ergriffen werden
dass wir genug gas haben wie eben
ausgeführt dass die lasten in
deutschland fair verteilt werden aber
nicht dass das land in einen zustand
gerät wie wir ihn auch an anderen
stellen schon hatten wo wir nicht über
die wichtigkeit von verschiedenen maßen
an streiten sondern darüber streiten und
für nicht putin seinen willen lassen
sollen das wäre fatal und deswegen ist
das was wir hier gerade machen eine
kollektive eine nationale
kraftanstrengung die wir nur gemeinsam
bestehen werden vielen dank
vielen dank ich habe die ersten fragen
ich fange an im raum herr delfs dann ja
kummer und frau herzog wir machen eine
frage nach der anderen also frage
antwort wenn es am ende knapp wird mit
der zeit bin ich aber erstmal ohne hair
days bitte herr mir ist können sie ganz
kurz noch mal erklären mit der
preisbildung als wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe werden ja die
konsumenten jetzt erstmal die
preiserhöhung gar nicht zu spüren
bekommen richtig sondern das ist ja eine
preisbildung erstmal am markt
stattfindet das heißt die gasunternehmen
bridas lieferanten erfahren diese
preissteigerung aber aber nicht erst mal
die konsumenten weil das wird nicht
weitergegeben ab welchem punkt wird es
weiter geben können sie das noch mal
kurz erklären und warum wird es jetzt
noch nicht weitergehen noch mal ganz
kurz für dumme
ganz so ist es nicht die preise werden
ja weitergegeben wenn sie auf ihre
rechnung geschaut haben werden sie
vermutlich gesehen haben dass dienst ist
die abschlagszahlung für das nächste
jahr schon angehoben wurden und zwar je
nach gas oder energieversorger deutlich
also da sind tatsächlich steigerung von
200 prozent zu verzeichnen und manchmal
mehr und das ist ein rollierendes system
die verträge werden in der regel
jährlich angepasst einige stadtwerke
oder versorger machen jetzt schon höhere
abschläge aber die preisvergabe erfolgt
schritt für schritt je nach stadtgebiet
oder nach haushalt schon jetzt davon
abgesetzt ist der paragraph 24 n sieg
der die preis weitergabe in den
bestehenden verträgen quasi sofort
ermöglicht der hintergrund ist dass die
versorgungsunternehmen
laufende verträge haben
die in der regel oder je nachdem wie
abhängig die von russischem gas sind das
jetzt ja blockiert wird und dann auf dem
gasmarkt auf dem spot-markt neu besorgt
werden muss zu deutlich höheren preisen
je nachdem welche verträge sie haben
machen sie mit jedem tag mit jeder woche
ein - und sollte dieses - so groß werden
dass die unternehmen ist nicht mehr
tragen können und sie umfallen droht der
gesamte markt irgendwann umzufallen also
einen basiseffekt im energiesystem die
versorger wie die stadtwerke nicht mehr
die stadtwerke nicht mehr die
nachgelagerten kunden und dann kann man
sich vorstellen was dann in deutschland
passiert dafür ist der 24 m sieg gedacht
aber eben wie gesagt noch nicht gezogen
weil wir schauen wollen wie sich die
situation weiterentwickelt dieser
paragraph er ist noch nicht das
schärfste schwert dass wir politisch in
der hand haben aber ein doch so schwer
dass es mit großem bedacht und rosa
bedacht angewandt werden muss
dann bitte an herrn meier
ja wenn wir schon beim § 24 sind sehen
wir gesagt dass in der presseaussendung
das ist eine verstetigung der gasmenge
lage dann eine anzeige durch die
bundesnetzagentur im bundesanzeiger
erforderlich machen würde das wäre ja
dann wenn der paragraf 24 in kraft
treten würde nach meinem verständnis
jetzt ist die frage wenn aus nord stream
1 nachdem wartungen im juli kein gas
mehr kommen wird wird dann § 24 zum
einsatz kommen
ich möchte nicht über den zeitpunkt
spekulieren so wie wir arbeiten das
haben sie ja eben gesehen werden wir
immer die grundlagen analysieren um dann
die vorbereiteten nächsten schritte zu
gehen aber sie haben im der
nebenbemerkung ein erwartbares und
einfach auf deutschland zukommen das
datum angesprochenen am 11.7 wird die
neueste mainz pipeline etatmäßig
gewartet diese wartungszeit hat in den
letzten jahren ungefähr zehn tage
gedauert in diesen zehn tagen wird kein
gas über north stream einst nach
deutschland fließen und entsprechend der
frage wie jetzt
effizienzmaßnahmen wirken wie wir
energie gas auf dem weltmarkt besorgen
können und die sich die einspeicherung
bis dahin entwickeln
verschlimmert sich im grunde dann in
dieser situation die lage und sollte es
nicht wieder angemacht werden die
gastwirte angekommen dann kann man sich
ausrechnen wie die grafik hoch gehalten
dass wir jetzt bei 40 prozent aus dem
belastung noch ein speichern können denn
die noch wegfallen werden würde ist
entsprechend weiterer maßnahmen
erforderlich machen ein kurzer hinweis
wir werden im laufe des tages die grafik
und die dahinterliegenden berechnung auf
veröffentlichen insofern können sie da
gerne auch noch nachschauen frau herzog
bitte haben sie schon super dann waren
die kollegen superschnell
alle länder die in der gasförderung sind
versuchen die kapazitäten zu erhöhen das
tun sie aus der solidarität heraus aber
natürlich auch weil die preise e mails
sind also es ist durchaus lukrativ im
moment gas auf den markt zu bringen die
betonung liegt sicherlich auch auf dem
moment das ist sicherlich ein
ausnahmezustand der so auf dauer nicht
bleiben wird das problem ist halt das
gasfelder zu entwickeln beziehungsweise
die kapazitäten zu steigern nicht so
ganz trivial ist man kann hier und da
noch bcm vielleicht zwei oder drei mehr
produzieren aber nicht auf schnitt große
gasfelder erschließen das dauert an
drei jahre oder 34 jahre
trotzdem bemühen sich alle länder das zu
tun und das funktioniert auch wir haben
gesehen dass aus den anderen ländern
größere gasmengen auf den markt gebracht
werden usa kanada norwegen
israel ägypten algerien alle tun ihren
beitrag und das sind die lieferanten
quellen die die dann genutzt werden vom
markt also was wir machen können was ich
machen kann muss die bundesregierung
macht ist diese länder zu ermutigen sie
anzusprechen die situation zu erklären
und die verträge werden aber ja nicht
von uns gemacht sondern dann von den
energieversorgungsunternehmen die sich
dann das günstigste gas auf dem markt
besorgen um dann ihren verpflichtungen
nachzukommen
dann würde ich jetzt einmal in den
digitalen raum wechseln jana wolf bitte
danach herr lochner und dann herr
wiedemann frau wolff sie machen den
anfang
vielen dank herr habe hannover kabel ich
würde gerne nochmal bei den entlassungen
nach waren sie sprachen von extremen
belastungen für viele menschen
unternehmen und unternehmern und das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen sein
wird
für eine faire aufteilung zu sorgen was
ist denn da an konkreten schritten schon
angedacht
inwiefern hat auf seinem
koalitionsausschuss eine rolle gespielt
und was bedeutet dass perspektivisch für
das ziel eines ausgeglichenen haushalts
und die einhaltung der schuldenbremse
vielen dank
der bundeskanzler hat die konzertierte
aktion einberufen
das ist eine antwort auf die
makroökonomische herausforderung die wir
haben hohe inflation die
mit allen mitteln die wir zur verfügung
haben nicht zu einer rezession werden
darf also das verhindert wird dass es
eine lohn-preis-spirale gibt hohe
inflation führt nach jeder denkbaren
form dazu dass man höhere lohnforderung
hat der verlust muss ja ausgeglichen
werden cora jugendförderung führen zu
noch höheren preisen führen zu einer
noch höheren inflation und so weiter und
so fort das ist mit den
arbeitgebervertretern mit den
gewerkschaften vor gesprochen worden
dass diese situation die dann aus der
hohen inflation einer rezession machen
kann wozu verhindert werden muss und wie
man sie verhindern kann das ist teil der
gespräche die der bundeskanzler führen
wird und die dann ja anfang juli
stattfinden werden dem möchte ich nicht
vorgreifen schon gar nicht würde ich die
zerstören indem ich das spiel mitmachen
das so gerne gespielt wird jeder hat
seine vorschläge auf dem markt und dann
werden die zerredet und am ende ist es
eine machtprobe zwischen parteien
welcher vorschlag dann am besten aus
kommt ich glaube hier muss man
tatsächlich mal ein bisschen vornehme
zurückhaltung üben und damit der
sinnvollste vorschlag oder die besten
ideen dann auch überhaupt nur eine
chance zu haben umgesetzt zu werden
das interessante damit will ich
schließen ist das und das ist eine nicht
schließen diese frage noch beantworten
das ist eine finde ich sehr
hoffnungsvolle erkenntnis ist dass die
klarheit der außergewöhnlichen situation
in der wir uns befinden bei arbeitgebern
den industrievertretern im mittelstand
standlern wie bei den gewerkschaften und
den arbeitnehmervertreterin voll da ist
und das die analyse auch eine sehr
gleiche ist denn
selbst oder gerade die arbeitgeber haben
ja kein interesse an einer schwächung
der kaufkraft bei gestörten lieferketten
und blockierten exportmärkten ist
natürlich zentral wichtig dass die
deutsche binnennachfrage erhalten bleibt
also gibt es ein interesse der
arbeitgeber an einer einhalten der
kaufkraft umgekehrt haben natürlich die
arbeitnehmer die
gewerkschaftsvertreterin kein interesse
dass deutschland ein und attraktiver
standort wird und branchen industrien
geschlossen werden oder abwandern also
gibt es quasi eine spiegel gleiche
erkenntnis der situation und wie die
aufgelöst werden soll wie man auch
politisch helfen kann sie aufzulösen das
wird hoffentlich dann in einem
vertrauten rahmen gegenstand der
gespräche der konzertierten aktion seien
dann bitte herr lochner
haben sie haben das
auktions der wind um damit die industrie
sozusagen zum gas sparen angeheizt wird
da ist jetzt ja der zeitraum im sommer
angegeben vielleicht können sie das noch
ein bisschen mehr einen grenzen den
zeitraum und was hören sie denn aus der
industrie zu bereitschaft an diesem
modell dann auch tatsächlich
teilzunehmen danke
die industrie
ist sehr bereit dieses modell anzunehmen
und setzt da ein stück weit drauf und
unterstützt uns auch bei der
zusammenstellung der daten also das ist
ein instrument das hoffentlich eine
gewisse wirkung und wenn man eine große
hoffnung hat mehr als eine gewisse
wirkung erzielen kann gas verbräuche zu
reduzieren ist natürlich jetzt schon
durch den preisdruck eigentlich das
gebot der stunde das tun auch viele ich
habe die zahlen genannt
geiste gasverbraucher zu reduzieren ist
aber natürlich auch mit kosten
möglicherweise verursacht wenn die dann
erworben werden können oder ausgeglichen
werden können die man geld dafür bekommt
wird es noch mal attraktiver dort
einzusteigen also die industrie ist der
ihm sehr sehr aufgeschlossen gegenüber
dass wir das modell erst im sommer an
den start bringen können liegt wie so
bei so viel daran dass es keine
vorbereitung dafür gab als ich ankam ich
habe das schon mehrfach erzählt hatte
man im grunde gar keine politischen
instrumente aber auch keine erkenntnisse
über das funktionieren des gasmarkts man
muss einfach einräumen dass viele
gesetze die eine trügerische sicherheit
ausgestrahlt haben überhaupt nicht für
diese situation gedacht und geschrieben
waren
vielleicht also ich nehme diese gas
notfallverordnung auf europäischer ebene
die er sagt wir schalten die industrie
hat die letztverbraucher sind geschützt
das szenario dass dieser verordnung zu
grunde liegt ist nicht eine
auseinandersetzung eine permanente
auseinandersetzung um eine fossile
energie versorgung sondern vielleicht
eine störung durch unfall also irgend
eine gasleitung geht kaputt und für ein
paar tage ist die versorgungssicherheit
in einer bestimmten region nicht
gewährleistet und das macht es natürlich
total sinn zu sagen ja dann fahren wir
halt die industrie prozesse für eine
woche unter das kann der staat
ausgleichen und dann ist die leitung
wieder heilige macht dann geht's wieder
weiter aber frieren soll da keiner für
diese situation die wir jetzt aber haben
ist diese verordnung sagen wir zu
pauschal so war die bundesnetzagentur
die abwehr gesetzt das ist ja ein altes
gesetz als bundes last verteiler für die
notfall stufe 1 treten soll und dann
regulieren soll welche falls die märkte
wirklich für sagen welche industrien
welche branchen welche region nicht mehr
mit gas versorgt werden natürlich darauf
angewiesen dass die kenntnisse über die
verbräuche in den regionen hat und über
energiesparen und wenn man richtig traf
denkt auch kenntnisse über die
lieferketten hätte gar keinen sinn
irgendein unternehmen iks rauszunehmen
weil man denkt man ja das ist vielleicht
entbehrlich und dann danach
festzustellen dass ganze ketten der der
der versorgung von deutschland dadurch
zusammenbrechen diese daten gab es gar
nicht noch nicht mal auf papier und was
die bundesnetzagentur unter hochdruck
macht mit dem
trading harburg ist diese daten zu
sammeln die daten der unternehmen
einzulegen in eine software die mit
einem algorithmus geführt und dann
ermöglicht je nach szenario die
richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen
diese plattform nutzen wir dann auch um
das markt instrument einzusetzen und
deswegen dauert es halt ein bisschen
länger es ist nicht die schlüssigkeit
der kolleginnen und kollegen die dazu
führt dass wir das erst im sommer
einsetzen können sondern die
schlüssigkeit der jahre zuvor und es ist
der fleiß der kollegin und der kollegen
dienen einer windeseile diese daten
gesammelt haben eine software ein
programm gebaut haben programmiert haben
das es uns ermöglicht dann kluge
entscheidungen zu treffen vor allem erst
einmal marktbasierte kluge entscheidung
zu treffen
man sieht allerdings auch dass
deutschland in der digitalisierung von
prozessen nicht nur beim ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien noch ganz schön
was aufzuholen hat herr wiedemann bitte
morgen eine frage dabei zum zeitpunkt
jetzt auszurufen warum haben sie das
nicht schon
woche gemacht denn die gas schlüsse
gegen jahr seit vergangenem dienstag
oder mittwoch stark zurück also was
braucht ihr jetzt noch diese
vorbereitung dass sie das heute machen
und ich schon ein paar tage eher
die durchdringung der marktanalyse ich
habe dich zu sagen ja gerade erwähnt wir
haben das einmal durchgerechnet und ich
will das noch mal sagen das ist hier
kein spiel das wir spielen das ausrufen
der alarmstufe ist eine
ein schritt der
außergewöhnlich ist
und ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass wir
in der gegenwart also für den tag für
die tage die wir gerade haben genug gas
bekommen und die speicher ja auch zu
nehmen also die speicherstände haben
sich in den letzten vor der reduktion
des gases hatten wir zu namen von 0 8
prozent 0 9 prozent teilweise also fast
knappes prozent jetzt hat er sich
halbiert in den letzten tagen schwanken
zwischen 0,3 und 0,5 in den letzten 24
stunden 0,3 der speicherstand betrieb
jetzt 58,7 prozent also wir nähern uns
langsam der 60 an also wenn man auf den
tag denkt man nach na ja die lage ist
doch trotz der reduktion bewältigt war
der markt funktioniert gas kommt nach
europa die speicher werden auch langsam
voller langsamer als zuvor wie sie
werden langsam voller und das was uns
alarmieren muss ist die perspektive und
die perspektive haben wir einmal sauber
durchgerechnet und so würde ich es gerne
halten uns nicht durch die irakischen
entscheidungen oder die strategischen
rateshow entscheidung von putin treiben
zu lassen sondern
möglichst alle szenarien politisch
vorbereitet zu haben und dann auf der
basis von tatsächlichen fakten lagen die
entscheidungen treffen
dann bitte her in und danach gehe ich
wieder in den physischen raum
guten morgen er ist christian timm ich
hätte eine frage ob es kalkulation in
ihrem haus gibt wie stark denn die
preise noch zulegen werden in den
nächsten monaten das ist ein blick in
die glaskugel
aber sie brauchen ja irgend eine
grundannahme um überhaupt auch ist
angebote für fleisch die verbraucher und
auch die wirtschafts kalkulieren zu
können
es gibt szenarien aber wir sie ist so
wie sie sagen die sind natürlich nicht
sehr verlässlich wir liegen jetzt für
die kalkulation die wir haben den
aktuellen gaspreis zu wohnen plus - also
in dem range indem wir sind ich habe bis
heute 125 euro dass es waren schon mal
130 nach der verkündigung von putin und
es ist ein bisschen runtergegangen auch
von der cdu schwankte zwischen 110 115
und 130 heute sind 125 der gaspreis war
aber auch schon mal bei 300 euro und ist
dann also bei kriegsbeginn ist dann
wieder runter gegangen also das sind
wirklich große sprünge am markt schwer
zu kalkulieren aber wir nehmen schon
einen höheren wert an
haben auch szenarien natürlich dass die
werte exorbitant hoch gehen natürlich
könnten sie auch theoretisch wieder
runter gehen nicht so sehr
wahrscheinlich dann bitte wieder in den
physischen raum finsler zunächst dann
herr traufetter und dann
habe ich wie sehr können sie für
deutschland tatsächlich planen da wir ja
zur solidarität mit anderen europäischen
ländern verpflichtet sind wie sehr hat
ihn dass die kalkulation kaputt und auch
eine ganz kurze zweite frage wie sehr
fühlen sie sich eigentlich allein in der
bundesregierung wo sie immer zum sparen
aufrufen aber die anderen eher steigen
ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht lange in
der bundesregierung sondern bin den
kollegen dankbar dass sie den weg
unterstützen dass sie das geld
bereitstellen die gestern 15 milliarden
ist ja auch kein pappenstiel
wurden bewilligt und zwar sowohl vom
finanzministerium wie im
haushaltsausschuss die hilfsprogramme
für die unternehmen die wir aufgestellt
haben alles ist einem guten
zusammenspiel erfolgt und gerade die
vorbereitenden maßnahmen die wir seit
dezember getroffen haben die kenntnisse
die wir erworben haben sind auch im
engen zusammenspiel mit dem kanzleramt
erworben also da ist es eine sehr gute
kooperation und von einsamkeit kann
keine rede sein die
erste frage war
die einer europäischen länder ich habe
schon gesagt im grunde verbietet sich
die frage jetzt hier über nationale
alleingänge nachzudenken gerade für
deutschland den geförderten nur noch ein
klein das ist also der
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck an dem
tag als später ist es ja heute klar wird
das wird richtig schwer im herbst im
winter das sind ernste gesichter die wir
seit tagen in der bundesregierung sehen
eben vor allen dingen von ihm von robert
habeck und das sind jetzt ernste worte
das ist ihr ausrufung der zweiten
alarmstufe beim gas der zweiten notfall
stufe und was das bedeutet das hat der
wirtschaftsminister eben jetzt ja eine
gute halbe stunde hier erklärt wir
wollen das noch mal ein ort mit unserem
bild reporter der diese pressekonferenz
vor ort miterlebt hat karl viktor wachs
unser bild reporter und zugeschaltet
dort im wirtschaftsministerium am
wirtschaftsministerium karl viktor sagt
uns einmal was bedeutet das für uns alle
also für uns gaskunden wie knapp könnte
tatsächlich das gas werden und ganz
wichtig ist was hat zu den preisen
gesagt hat robert hatte
also das gas könnte wirklich knapp
werden das hat er ja auch schon
angetippt angekündigt es wird ernst um
60 prozent sind die importe hat schon
reduziert wir wissen nicht wie es mit
putins krieg in der ukraine weiter geht
und deswegen hat er jetzt auch diesen
schritt unternommen es gibt da drei
stufen die notfall stufe die alarmstufe
und die früh warnstufe die früh
warnstufe haben viele nicht mitgekriegt
es schon seit ende märz in kraft jetzt
sind wir auf der zweiten stufe und er
hat ja so ein bisschen durchscheinen
lassen es kommt vielleicht auch die
dritte und für uns deutsche fühlt sich
das jetzt komisch an es ist sommer ist
es extrem warm und wir können uns gar
nicht vorstellen was jetzt heizen sparen
wir auch bedeuten soll aber robert
habeck hat er ganz klar gesagt
hydraulischen abgleich soll man machen
ich weiß nicht was das ist weiß ich
fußball sehen also es wird auf jeden
fall kompliziert er hat ganz klar weg so
auch alles verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher jetzt schon aufgerufen
hydraulischer also muss ich auch nicht
ein bauer leben muss man sich wohl heute
meine hause optimiert ist aber ganz klar
es geht jetzt schon an den geldbeutel
ist ja und jetzt schon daran zu sagen es
wird gespart gas ist jetzt ein knappes
gut wir sind hier auch schon
durchgegangen gasheizungen mit gas
kochen also wirklich das ist jetzt etwas
das jetzt schon spürbar für uns wird so
zumindest viktor haben wir das alle hier
aufgefasst ja
ja das und es wird vor allem peinlich
wenn man jetzt noch viel gas benutzt das
heißt man muss sich darauf einstellen
dass sollte gegenwärtig sagen rot
benutzt aber viel gas wir haben noch
eine ernste situation macht das mal
nicht und ich glaube darauf haben die
meisten deutschen keine lust ja danke
dir bild reporter karl viktor wachs dort
am wirtschaftsministerium wo robert
habeck noch spricht das wesentliche
haben wir aber gehört und das ja sind
wichtige worte jetzt gewesen von robert
habeck aber worte die nichts gutes
verheißen das ist der startpunkt ab
heute muss deutschland gas sparen das
ist die ganz klare botschaft von robert
habeck er hat sie alle zu hause uns alle
in deutschland angesprochen hat auch
gesagt da wahrscheinlich sparen sie ja
längst aber ab jetzt ist es ernst ab
jetzt müssen wir das tun und ganz
wichtig dieses datum noch mal im juli
niveau die parteien sowieso schon mal
dich erwartet wird gewartet wird nord
stream 1 das wird sozusagen der test
möglicherweise kommt diese pipeline dann
mit noch weniger gas nur zurück oder gar
nicht mehr also eine ernster tag heute
gas alle haben in deutschland